ก็
สวัสดีค่ะคุณฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกๆคน
เปลี่ยนทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนทุกคนคนทุกคน
ทุกคนโหฟังแล้วเนี่ยน่าจะมีนักเรียนนัก
เรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนเยอะมาก
นักเรียนนะทุกๆคนคือ
1 คน 2 คน 3 คน 4 คน 5 คนขายค่ะเยอะมากๆ
ๆก่อนที่เราจะมาเริ่มเรียนกันครูฟ้า
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันนี้วันพุธวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 10 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรเดือนพฤศจิกายนค่ะเดือน
อากายนต์เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือน
ที่ 11 หากปีพศอะไรคะอีผช
2560 ปีคศราคาดีข้อ 2
0215 แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวาน
นี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันอังคารที่ 9 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนค่ะเดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าเป็นเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ค่ะปีพศ.ราคะ
2021 แล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรพรุ่ง
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันพฤหัสที่เท่าไหร่
คะ
วันพฤหัสที่ 10  11 ค่ะ 21 น้องเดือนอะไร
คะคุณฟ้าเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่
เดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะปีพต
2564 ปีคศหละคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันที่ 11 เดือน 11
หู
เต้นตื่นเต้นหรอตอนนี้ยังเพราะว่าตอนนี้
นี้โอเคลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น
จะ
15:00 นกี่นาที
38 นาทีค่ะบ่ายสามโมง 38 นาที
แต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยวันนี้ยังเป็นวันที่ 10
สมัยเดือน 11 อยู่ยังเป็นวันที่ 10 เดือน
11 ปี
2021 ไปแล้วเวลา 15:00 นเนี่ยเป็นกลาง
วันหรือว่ากลางคืน
อะไรเพราะว่า
ใน 1 วัน 1 วันเนี่ย
1 วันนี้กี่ชั่วโมงคะคุณฟ้า
1 วันมี 24 ชั่วโมงในหนึ่งวันครูฟ้ามี 24
ชั่วโมง
ครูหญิงมี 24 ชั่วโมงให้นักเรียนมี
24 ชั่วโมงคิดว่าเหมือนกันเหมือนกันจน
จันทร์ทุกคนน้ำนี่เวลา 24 ชั่วโมงมีหนึ่ง
อ่ะแล้ว 24 ชั่วโมงเนี่ยก็จะ
แบ่งครึ่งไหมแบ่งครึ่งเป็น
12 ชั่วโมง
ก็
12 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
12  12 ชั่วโมงแรกก็จะเป็นเวลากลางวัน
3 วัน
กลางวันแล้วอีก 12 ชั่วโมงเป็นเวลาอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้าเป็นเวลากลางคืนค่ะกลางซื้อนกะ
กลางคืนแล้วก็ตอนนี้สมัยตอนนี้แหละเป็น
เวลาบ่าย 15:00 น
กี่นาทีคะตอนนี้ตอนนี้ 40 นาทีแล้วค่ะ
40 นาทีบ่าย 3 โมง 40 นาทีเนี่ยผู้หญิง
ถามว่าเป็นเวลากลางวันหรือว่ากลางคืน
บ่าย 3:40 นเป็นเวลากลางวันค่ะอย่างวัน
เพราะแล้วเรารู้ได้ยังไง
ทำไมกลางวัน
เพราะว่ามีพระอาทิตย์หรือพระอาทิตย์นี้
เราเรียกว่าพระอาทิตย์
พระอดิศักดิ์รางวัลเนี่ยก็จะเห็นพระ
อาทิตย์ฉันในเวลากลางวันอาทิตย์
มาแล้ว Go
[เพลง]
38 องศาเซลเซียสใช่ไหมกลางวันเนี่ยอ่ะ
ร้อน
ก่อนหน้าในค่ะแล้วครูฟ้าเวลากลางวันเนี่ย
เราบอกว่ามี 12 ชั่วโมง
แล้วไม่ฮากลางวันเนี่ยมีเวลาตั้งแต่กี่
โมงคะ
ตั้งแต่
6:00 น
6:00 น 6:00 นเช้านะคะจนถึงกี่โมงคะจน
ถึง
18:00 นหรออันนี้แบบไทยนะคะ 18:00 นสมัย
18:00 นเห็นไหมเจ็ดโมงเย็นน
งั้นแล้วไอ้ลากลางคืนน่ะคะเวลาก็คือเนี่ย
เริ่มตั้งแต่กี่โมง
เริ่มตั้งแต่
18:00 นแล้วถูกไหมคะ
18:00 น
ต้นถึงกี่โมงคะ 18:00 น
6:00 นค่ะ
พรุ่ง
12 ชั่วโมง 12 ชั่วโมง
เวลากลางวันก็มีพระอาทิตย์แล้วก็ร้อนแล้ว
เวลากลางคืนเราเห็นอะไรคะมีอะไร
เวลากลางคืนมีพระจันทร์ค่ะโอเคค่ะพระ
จันทร์อาจารย์แล้วมีอะไรอีกค่ะคุณฟ้ามี
ดาวนับดาวในรูปมีดาวกี่ดวง
มีดาว
151 ดวงแต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยขอลากลางคืน
เนี่ยมีดาว 1 ดวงไหม
ไม่ใช่
เวลากลางคืนมีดาวเยอะๆ Down  Down  Down
Down  Down
บอกมากๆ
ดาวเยอะๆ
แล้วไม่ทันน่ะ
ไม่รู้อ๋ออ๋อแล้วพระจันทร์หรอคะเวลากลาง
คืนมีพระจันทร์กี่ดวง
เวลากลางคืนมีพระจันทร์ 1 ดวงค่ะหนึ่งดวง
เนาะพระจันทร์มีหนึ่งดวงเวลากลางวันมีพระ
อาทิตย์กี่ดวงนี่ 1 ดวงค่ะมีหนึ่งดวงแต่
ด้วยใช่มั้ย
กูฟ้าแล้วเวลากลางวันเวลากลางวันครูฟ้าทำ
อะไร
เวลากลางวันถ้าไปกลางวัน
6:00 นถึง 18:00 นทำเราเนาะครูฟ้าผู้
หญิงเวลากลางวันทำอะไรเวลากลางวันก็ตื่น
ใช่ไหมว่าแน่นอนแล้วก็ตื่น
แล้วก็กินอาหารเช้าขอกิน
เราก็สอนภาษาไทยแวะพูดพูดพูดพูดภาษาไทย
แล้วก็มีนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ย
กลางวันครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าก็สอนภาษาไทยนัก
เรียนเวลากลางวันก็ก็เรียนภาษาไทยเรียน
ภาษาไทยใช่ค่ะคิดว่าน่าจะใช่นะชายแล้ว
เวลากลางคืนเวลากลางคืนครูฟ้าครูหญิงนัก
เรียนทำนะคะลากลางเครื่องเวลากลางคืนก็
นอน
นอนตอนเล่นเกม
เล่นเกมก็ได้สมัยก็แตกไม่ต้องสอนภาษาไทย
ไม่เรียนภาษาไทย
นอน
นอนเยอะๆนะนอนเหมือนกรูฟ้าบอกใช่มั้ยกลาง
คืนนอน
กลางวัน
ตื่น
ตื่นใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าอ่ะเนี่ยชอบ
กลางวันหรือว่าชอบกลางคืน
รูปช้าชอบ
กลางคืนค่ะแต่กูฟ้าชอบกลางคืนล่างขึ้น
ใหม่ค่ะทำไมชอบกลางคืน
น้องนอน
ไม่ชอบนอนแล้วทำไมชอบกลางคืน
เพราะว่าตอนกลางคืนไม่ทำงานต่อ
ไม่ต้องสอนภาษาไทย
ไม่ต้องพูดภาษาไทย
ไม่ต้องสอนภาษาไทยใช่มั้ยอ้ะมักมีปาสนะ
ไม่มีคลาสไม่ทำงานตอนก็สบายสบาย
กินเล่นเกมดู YouTube ดูซีรีส์
ตกกลางคืนก็เลย
ครูฟ้าชอบตอนกลางคืนอ่ะท่าม
กลางคืนแล้วครูหญิงมาคะผู้หญิงชอบบางกลาง
วันหรือตอนกลางคืนครูหญิงก็ก็เหมือนครู
ฟ้าผู้หญิงทอด
กลางคืนไหมอ่ะเอ้าก็บอกแล้วกลางวันร้อน
ร้อน
38 องศาเซลเซียสใช่มั้ยกลางคืนเนี่ยไม่
ร้อนกลางคืนที่ประเทศไทยตอนนี้ก็อาจจะ
ประมาณ 30  -
30 องศาเซลเซียส
คนไทยเนี่ยไม่ร้อนสบายๆเย็น
เย็นใช่มั้ยเย็นกลางวันร้อนกลางคืนใจเย็น
Bring ก็เลยชอบกลางคืน
ก็กลางคืน
เป็นคนกลางคืนทุกคนกลางคืนผู้หญิงคนกลาง
คืนจ่ายค่ะแล้วก็อะไรกลางคืนเนี่ยก็เป็น
เวลานอนจะรักนอนผู้หญิงชอบนอนไหมคะใช่ค่ะ
ครูหญิง
นอนพออาทิตย์ได้ไหมโอโหอกกลางคืนเย้
นอน
กลางวันตื่นแล้วก็สอนภาษาไทยมีคลาสไปพอ
กลางคืนหล่อนอนก็เลยชอบกลางคืน
นักเรียนบอกว่าครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงห้อกลาง
คืน
ดีแล้วครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงเปิดฟาสเรียนภาษา
ไทยตอนกลางคืนโอเคไหม
มีคะจรคืนตอนกลางคืนรูปฟ้ามีคะกลางคืน
โอเคว่ากูช้าตื่นตื่นกลางคืนกูฟ้ากับ
สวัสดีค่ะ
ครูหญิงช่วงเวลากลางคืน
ผู้หญิงเป็นอะไร
ไม่ได้ครูหญิงเนี่ยเปิดฟาสกลางคืนกลางคืน
ที่ไทยนะ
ไม่ได้
ต้องเป็นปางวันอะไรคุณครูคะเป็นนกฮูกค่ะ
นกฮูกเนี่ยตื่นกลางคืนใช่มั้ยนอน
กลางวันเหมือนครูฟ้า
เหมือนกันนะค่ะนกฮูกนกฮูก
ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนเนี่ยชอบ
กลางวันหนึ่งนักหรือกลางคืนนะคะนักเรียน
ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเค้าได้
เหมือนเดิมเทอมใหญ่แล้ว
นักเรียนก็บอกนะคือเวลาเค้าคุณฟ้าผู้หญิง
ลืมอะไรก็เร่งแรงเลยนะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเหมือนนกฮูกเหมือนนกฮูกเพราะ
ว่ากูป๊า
ชอบตอนกลางคืนก่อนก็คือเนี่ยไม่นอน
ครูหญิงเนี่ยพอกลางคืนแล้วก็นอนใช่มั้ย
นอนหน้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบกลางคืนไม่นอนไม่มี
ครับไม่ทำทำงานแม่ตอนกลางคืนครูฟ้าทำอะไร
ฟาร์โก้วาดรูปจะวาดรูปที่ไวท์บอร์ดเหรอคะ
นี่สวยบอดแล้วก็วาดรูปแบบผู้หญิงหรอผู้
หญิงวาดพระอาทิตย์
วาดพระจันทร์วาดดาวฟ้าวาดรูปพี่ไวท์บอร์ด
เหรอคะไม่ใช่
ใช่แล้วครูฟ้าวาดรูปตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยว่า
ที่ไหนอ่ะกูพามีไอแพด / ป่นมีอันหากูฝา
เขาใช้ iPad อยู่
แต่จะไม่เหมือนกันนะคะแล้วก็มีปากกา
เดี๋ยวอาใช้กับ iPad เนาะใส่กับ iPad มา
แล้วก็ว่าลูบว่าเฮงๆ
คุณครูฟ้า
วาดรูปแบบนี้สวยไหมคะ
วาดรูปแบบนี้ค่ะวาดรูป
ครูฟ้าไม่ได้วาดรูปนี้นะคะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่อันนี้ให้ดูว่าอันนี้คือการ
วาดรูปสมัยบ้านดูในไอแพด
นอกจากวาดรูปแล้วตอนกลางคืนฟ้าทำอะไรอีก
ไหมว่ามึงไม่นอน
ไม่นอนใช่ไหมคะก็จะอ่าน
อ่านการ์ตูนค่ะอ่านการ์ตูนที่ไหนคะใน
แอพพลิเคชั่นค่ะอ๋อ
ใช่มั้ย
แล้วก็มีการ์ตูน
หือก็กดเข้าไป
แล้วก็จะเป็นการ์ตูน
ครูฟ้าอ่านพี่ตูนไม่อ่านการ์ตูนที่
โทรศัพท์โทรศัพท์
เวลากลางคืนใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าป่ะรู้สึกสบาย
ๆเนาะตอนกลางคืนสมัยตอนกลางคืน
แล้วครูฟ้าก็อ่านการ์ตูนใช่มั้ยอ่าน
การ์ตูนเสร็จกว่าก็จะมี
ดิสคอร์ด
อะไรคะดิสคอร์ดดิสคอร์ดเนี่ยเอาไว้คุยกับ
เพื่อน
โหล
สวัสดีทำอะไรคุยกับเพื่อน
ว่ามีเพื่อน 1  2  3  4  5 เดือนเพื่อนๆ
เพื่อนๆครูฟิตคุยโทรศัพท์กับเพื่อนเนี่ย
ตอนกลางคืนก่อนเพื่อนครูฟ้าก็ไม่ขั้นตอน
ตอนกลางคืนให้อะเพื่อนพูดไม่นอน
เหมือนกัน
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยนอนตอนกลางคืนตอนกลางวันน่ะ
โอเค Hello เป็นยังไงอ่ะคุยโทรศัพท์ได้
แต่ครูฟ้าคุยโทรศัพท์ก่อนกลางคืนนะคะ
มันตอนกลางวันครูฟ้าสอนภาษาไทยมีคลาสภาษา
ไทยก็อาจจะไม่มีเวลาคุยเป็นยังไงบ้างทำไม
คุยโทรศัพท์
โอนกลางคืนก็เลยเป็นเวลาพักผ่อน
วิไลทาย
ครูบาก็สบายๆทำอะไรก็ได้กินดูซีรีส์คุย
โทรศัพท์วาดรูป
ๆสบายๆ
แล้วนักเรียนสมัยนักเรียนเนี้ยนักเรียน
ชอบกลางวันหรือว่าชอบกลางคืนหรือว่ากลาง
วันทำอะไรกลางคืนทำอะไรเราก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะคะนี้เราก็ต้องไปแล้วนะคะเปลี่ยน
ใช่ค่ะก่อนไปอย่าลืมทำอะไรคะอย่าลืมกด
like กด Share กด Subscribe ไปหานัก
เรียนใจขาดแล้วมาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้า
เนาะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะอ่า